كيف يعمل منطاد التجسس لمحه ادق تظهر
كيفيه استخدام هذه المعدل القديمه في عالم
التجسس الحديث عندما اكتشفت الولايات
المتحده الهيكل الطائر فوق اراضيها امتنعت
عن اسقاطه معلله ذلك بانه لا يشكل اي
تهديد على سلامه الناس على الارض كونه
يحلق على ارتفاعات تتجاوز حركه مرور
الطيران التجاري والعسكري بكثير
المناطير عاده تعمل على ارتفاع من 24
كيلومترا الى 37 كيلومترا وفي منطقه تعرف
بجاره الفضاء حيث لا تطير الطائرات
التجاريه ابدا على ارتفاع يزيد عن 12
كيلومترا و500 متر
اما بالنسبه للطائرات المقاتله فهي تحلق
بعلو متوسط بين الارتفاعين حده الاقصى 20
كيلومترا بينما ترتفع الاقمار الاصطناعيه
عاده الى 241 كيلومترا ولدت تحليق في الجو
تستخدم هذه المناطيد مزيجا من التيارات
الهوائيه وجيوب الهواء المضغوط التي يمكن
ان تكون شكلا من اشكال التوجيه ويتم ملء
هيكل المنطاد الرئيسي بغاز الهيليوم او
الهيدروجين وهما اخف من الهواء والذين
يعدان وقودا لمحركي المنطاد ويعاد شحنهما
بواسطه الواح الخلايا الشمسيه مناطيض
التجسس تحتوي ايضا على انظمه الرادار
المحموله جوا ذات القدره على تزويد
الطاقهم الارضى بمعلومات استخباريه عن
مساحات شاسعه علاوه على ذلك يحمل منطاد
التجسس كاميرات للرؤيه الليليه والنهاريه
وفيما يتعلق بالبالون الصيني الذي شغل
مؤخرا فحجمه يعادل ثلاث حافلات في حين ان
بالونات الطقس عاده ما يتوسع عرضها الى
نحو سته امتار اذا ماذا يحدث عندما ينهي
المنطاد رحلته اذا لم يتم اسقاطه فسيسقط
تلقائيا في مكان ما